voici maintenant ch
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
navour
bonsoirour trs heureux de avir plate
tout le mond en parle merci ça va Bonne
Année 2004 oui bonne année à vous vous
avez vous avez fait quoi pour les fêtes
rien rien moi les fêtes c'est pas
important pour moi ah ouais non non
pendant des années les fêtes c'était une
matinée de plus ou quand c'était pas
deux début faut rappeler pour les gens
qu'une matinée en plus ça dire du
travail ça veut dire une représentation
pas une grassce matinée attendez
redites-moi ça parce que je suis pas
comme le Président vous disiez une
matinée en plus ça représentait une
matinée une matinée de de musical vous
voulez dire un spectacle en plus oui oui
peut-être les gens navaient pas compris
chez eux
Charles ah peut-être ça va être ça tout
le temps Charles sans déconner moi
je alors aussi si
on
bien
char est-ce que est-ce que vous avez
pris des bonnes résolutions pour l'année
2004 ben je vais travailler ah ouais
d'accord c'est la meilleur des
résolutions alors vous sortez un nouvel
album chez capital Imi qui s'appelle je
voyage et avant d'en parler on va faire
un résumé des épisodes précédents Didier
je me voyais déjà en haut de la fiche en
fois plus gros que n'importe qui mon nom
s'éalait je me voyais déjà à riche
signant mes poteaux aux admirateurs qui
se bousculaient Dieu que tu as changé en
5 ans tu te laisses aller tu te laisses
aller tu es belle à regarder tes bat
tombant sur tes
chaussures et ton vieux peignoir mal
fermé ettait bigouis quelle
allure il faut
savoir encore
sourire quand le meilleur s'est retiré
bien voir les comédiens voir les
musiciens voir les magiciens qui
arrivent bien voir les comédiens voir
les musiciens voir les magiciens qui
arrivent quand la mer est grise et qu'on
l' un peu dans le petit bois de trousse
chemise on fait des bêtises souviens-toi
nous deux on était parti pour trousse
chemise sur ma
vie j'ai juré que mon cœur ne
battait jamais pour aucun un autre cœur
et tout est perdu car il ne va plus mais
il
pleure mon amour dessus et pourtant
pourtant je n'aime que toi et pourtant
pourtant je n'aime que toi de l'espoir
riche de joie et de
folie il faut
boire jusqu'à l'ivresse
sa
jeunesse ils sont venus ils sont tous là
dès qu'ils ont entendu ce cri elle va
[Musique]
mourir
formable
plus bleu que le bleu de tes yeux je ne
vois rien de mieux même le bleu des
cieux plus blanc que tes cheveux dorés
ne peut s'imaginer même le blond des blé
que ces tristes
venis autant les amour
Mor que c'est
triste ne s'aime plus hier
encore j'avais 20 ans je caressais le
temps et jouais de la vie comme on joue
de l'amour et je vivais la nuit sans
compter sur mes jours qui je vous parle
d'un temps que les moins de 20 ans ne
peuvent pas
connaître mon MRE en ce
tempslà accroché ces lità jusque sous
nos fenêtres et si l'umble garni qui
nous servait de N ne payit pas de M
c'est là qu'on connu moi qui criéais
famille et toi qui posais nu chaque rue
chaque
pierre semblait nêtre qu'à
nous nous étions seuls sur
Terre à
Paris au moi
lour
AMEN
z-moi au bout de la terre emmenez-moi au
pays des merveilles il me semble que la
misère serait moins pénible au soleil
désormais on ne nous verra plus
ensemble
désormais mon cœur vivra sous
lescombres
non je n'ai rien
oublier mourir
[Musique]
d'aimour comm on le PE de n'importe
quoi le bruit familier de la boîte à la
mode oh luur psyé
curieux j'habite seul avec maman dans un
très vieil
appartement rue
saraz j'ai pour me tenir
compagnie une tortue de
Canarie et une
ch pour laisser maman reposer très
souvent
je fais le
marché et la cuisine mes amis mes amours
mes
[Musique]
enmêtresoyageoyage un peu plus de jours
et de
nuit de
voyage en
voyage à travers un rêve et un somis la
ou
d'orage d'un pied léger ou
d'unou de
mirage en
mirage par la
mémoire et par
amour
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
Thierry Orlando exige le clip